look you so much to cover the mouth what
alright damn pride let's remember those
procedures what are the others going but
that's the wrong way we've already tried
that remember your exit points exit
people you're too heavy I don't need you
pal fear is what it's all about you
cannot sell while undergoing fear you
need to vanquish fear one must wrestle
fear to the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan hi Ryan
you seem nice where are all the animals
oh right okay nice everybody enjoying
their meal hey babe yeah how about we
take the beer sign down and tell our
guests leave and then we can discuss it
no no I'm gonna leave it up I didn't get
ties a whole room together
okay Jane thanks hunters very talented
you know what is that good least he's an
artist
PFT I'm a screenwriter no all you do is
you get me to try to work on my rich
friends for an investment opportunity
man I would love to burn your handles
you run it you buy it
oh but you're a barley by verse
[Music]
[Music]
Oh balls
everyone please relax I think you're
gonna like this surprise guest
happy birthday games Oh get out skeleton
man here anything I said look happy he's
happy because he's insane you know what
that's a perfect example of the kind of
awareness we need to generate where's
the nurse
this is the reason we're here hello my
god oh hey no you Elizabeth Yeah right
Wow very cool he went back and got your
degree I would like you to accept this
check for 340 dollars made out to
science make sure that that gets into
the right hands
Erin there's a call for you on line one
who is it she says salvation no last
name
yeah hello you once put me on a list of
the losers in the office well this loser
just got your biggest client to give him
all their business so hire me back that
business is yours don't and I will find
another buyer you're blackmailing me
it's just business Wow I will not be
blackmailed by some ineffectual
privilege defeats soft penis debutante
oh you want to start a street fight with
me bring it on but you're gonna be
surprised by how ugly it gets you didn't
even know my real name I'm The Lizard
King does everyone know my boyfriend Bob
Vance Kevin Malone Bob Vance Vance
refrigeration Stanley Hudson Bob Vance
Vance refrigeration
Ryan Howard Bob Vance Vance
refrigeration
what line of work you in Bob so how do
you search by keyword phrase try profits
don't try Michael Scott Michael Bosse
and funny oh my god
Wow email from Stanley Stanley terribly
nice guy sorry I didn't write back
sooner I can't go to the game tonight
because my boss Michael is an ass and
making me stay late well hola hola
necesito un bueno worker to export say
come on okay hey no vamos Vanessa Senora
no sandy no con muchos otros you know
well the nadie
we don't go with that man I've seen
several men go with them and and don't
come back
perdido me was we've lost friends no
Californios we don't know what he does
with them no killers you Tomas I don't
want to talk about it anymore I pick up
day laborers and tell them that they'll
get paid at 6 p.m. at 5:45 a certain i
NS agent by the name of Moses root
throws them in the back of a van drops
them off in the middle of Harrisburg and
tells them it's Canada oh let me go hola
blessing bueno worker see yo muy bueno
worker yeah el accent Oh donde are you
from Scranton ye before that not
Philadelphia you speak English yes I'm
really good at English ok good me too
get in the car who is this guy by our
cars that is my new maintenance worker
Nate and you'll be happy to know that
he's taking care of that hornets nest
that you've been griping about I got to
stock up my dress or Hornet I've left
him all the tools he needs this is do or
die if he chooses correctly he'll
conquer the Hornets and if he doesn't
he'll die I beg your pardon
when did the phrase Do or Die become so
corrupted is that a blowtorch no no no
just a choice yes it's very very far
away go away no what is he doing oh you
can I have that no okay I am going to
count down from five five four I'm not
kidding
three two - I had to do that yes screw
it all right are we good
you're okay
he's okay thank you home Michael
no mmm this is the best burger I've ever
had babe no babe I've told you about
I need something bad hmm you stole this
huh for you ma'am
[Music]
[Music]
you